uh this is a very personal story for me
i'm kind of kidding but people know i'm
supposed to go to a wedding in italy
in early september and i've been
wondering
will americans be allowed in uh the
uh washington post is now reporting that
the european union will be reopening
their borders
to the vaccinated american population
very very soon the european union
announced uh
this morning that they will be opening
the borders to
vaccinated americans after more than a
year
during which travel has been
significantly restricted
uh this is a washington post report
which says the decision
will throw open europe's doors to
tourist business
and other travel after a long stretch in
which most of those from outside the 27
nation block
have not been allowed in it will hearten
those i am feeling heartened i admit it
it will hearten those who have missed
wandering the continent's
ancient streets as well as europeans
whose livelihoods
depends on tourist cash one final round
of approvals is necessary in the coming
days but the sign off is no longer in
doubt
the plan was agreed upon by ambassadors
today the timing of when borders will
actually open is not yet clear but it
could be
within days and certainly by the end of
june
um the european council quote now
recommends that rec
that member states ease restrictions in
particular for those
with an eu authorized vaccine that would
mean
all of the vaccines authorized in the
u.s
would get the green light but vaccines
currently manufactured in russia and
china that's the
sputnik and the sinovac vaccine
would not at least at this time qualify
you for entry to the european union
this guidance from the european union is
not binding meaning a country could say
we're not letting anybody in
or a country could say we'll let people
in with the sputnik vaccine or the
sinovac vaccine or
the bleach injections or whatever they
want to do but this is the guidance from
the european union
it has been a massive struggle in europe
greece opened relatively early um
croatia is open estonia uh there are way
i mean listen if
the truth is if you're determined to go
somewhere
you can almost certainly go and i know
you know 10 15 people who
who have done it i have friends who
wanted to go visit family in france
france was allowing people coming from
the
uk the uk was allowing americans with a
14-day quarantine so
they went to the uk hung out 14 days
worked remotely then went to france like
you
you could do it all along but that's not
going to get the tourism industry
restarted so we are seeing a definite
change at this point in time
now you could you will have a situation
where you will have vaccinated americans
going to countries
where the local population is not yet
highly vaccinated now per the cdc
although they've not yet
really changed country-specific travel
guidelines the cdc says
if you are vaccinated just about any
activity is safe even without a mask
although you should wear a mask in
certain situations as dictated by
local law regulation business policy
whatever a
third of eu residents have gotten at
least one dose of a vaccine
in the u.s about half of americans have
gotten at least one dose so
you will have it's basically six weeks
behind
europe is six weeks behind the united
states given how slowly the initial
vaccine rollout was in europe
it's actually pretty good that they're
only six weeks behind
and um there are going to be probably
significant accelerations as more and
more
vaccines will flow in the direction of
europe now
i've said for a while over time
the number of people who don't want the
vaccine in the u.s is going to decline
because there are going to be more and
more things you need to be vaccinated in
order to do
one of those things now that you will be
able to do with vaccinated is go to
europe
i don't know that the anti-vax
republicans are that big on europe
and what i mean by that is a lot of the
same people
that still don't want a vaccine which is
41 of republicans
a lot of them are probably the types of
people who see the concept of europe as
sort of like
[ __ ] flamboyant and socialist and
they don't care about europe and they're
not interested in going to europe and in
fact
being told you can only go to europe
with a vaccine it might make them more
uh it might reinforce their anti-vaccine
beliefs
maybe not but we are seeing the decline
in anti-vaxx
slow down last month 43 of republicans
did not want the vaccine
this month it's 41 of republicans it is
a decline
but it's a very very slow decline so
great news for who is this great news
for
this is great news for would-be
travelers this is great news
simply for those who want to see the
world start to be able to come out
of what was a very dark winter uh winter
of 2020
um and hopefully we will continue to see
those cases and deaths decline i i am
cautiously optimistic
that we will and we will all be
celebrating
on memorial day weekend not only with
maybe barbecues but also with a crazy
my accountant is saying david don't do
it my staff is saying david don't even
think about it
my lawyer is saying i would reconsider
but i'm going to do it
on memorial day we are offering an
historic
memorial day membership special be
notified of it
on memorial day by simply getting on my
mailing list you go to davidpakman.com
you type in your email address if you
know what it is and you will be notified
on memorial day
how do you do it instruction's
forthcoming
on may 31st we'll take a quick break let
me know your thoughts about the
reopening i'm on twitter at deepakman
and we have a really packed show for you
today